conçu au début des années 30 comme un
avion d'affaires à hautes performances
le prototype du bristol beinheim fut
présenté au britannique par l'une de ses
vedettes l'ordre aux en mer
ce monoplan révolutionnaire annoncé la
fin de l'ère des biplans et lorsqu'il
entra en service en 1937 il était le
plus rapide et le plus perfectionné des
avions de la rn
2 ans plus tard plus d'un millier
étaient en service et au déclenchement
de la guerre les blés naïm étaient les
plus nombreux des avions de la rs
comme élément essentiel de la puissance
aérienne britannique le bimoteur étaient
destinés à supporter l'essentiel des
premiers combats mais avec l'avancée
technologique de l'aéronautique il fut
rapidement dépassée en termes d'armement
comme de performance par les chasseurs
allemands
les pertes des blés nine pour les deux
premières années de la guerre furent
tout simplement effrayante souvent
employés dans des missions pour
lesquelles il n'était pas conçu le blé
naïm et ses équipages envoyés en france
subir les pertes les plus élevées de
toute la ras durant toute la seconde
guerre mondiale
mais pour éviter le sabre et le moral de
la nation britannique la propagande se
concentra sur les chasseur monoplace
spitfire et hurricane bien plus glamour
la contribution du blé naïma la cause
alliée fut injustement passer sous
silence et dans l'histoire de la guerre
aérienne il fut largement oubliée
cependant l'avion fut loyal et ses
équipages il jouait son rôle pleinement
autant comme chasseur que bombardier de
jour comme de nuit et jusqu'à la fin de
la guerre les succès de cet avion
élégant furent nombreux
il fut le premier avion britannique a
franchi la frontière allemande pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale est effectué
à la première attaque contre un navire
allemand le admiral cher
il fut le premier avion a participé à
une offensive aérienne est le premier à
effectuer des missions d'intrusion
nocturne
il permis d'expérimenter le
développement du radar embarqué et
emporta de nuit le premier radar
d'interception opérationnel
il coula le premier ou boat et fut le
seul avion de la rfa servir sur tous les
fronts au sein de tous les grands
commandements de la r f
ces équipages faire montre de la plus
grande bravoure mission après mission
affrontèrent leurs ennemis dans des
actions parfois à la limite du suicide
la victoria cross fut attribué à plus de
pilotes de blé naïm que deux pilotes de
riz khan et le spitfire réunis
nous bristol blé naïve
en 1933 la bristol aeroplane compagnie
annonce à l'étude d'un bristol team 135
un monoplan rapide capable d'emporter
jusqu'à huit passagers
la construction de cet avion serait
entièrement métallique et il serait
équipé de deux bristol akuila de 500
chevaux en étoile refroidi par air
en 1934 une maquette échelle 1 était
prête à être exposé au salon de
l'aéronautique à paris prévu l'année
suivante
entre-temps l'ordre aux maires
propriétaire du daily mail avait gardé
un oeil sur son grand rival propriétaire
du daily express lord beaverbrook
pour ce voyage d'affaires bieber moque
avait commandé le plus récent des avions
de ligne léger américain le lockheed 14
en réponse rosemère décida de se
procurer un avion entièrement
britannique capable d'établir un réseau
européen de vols sans escale entre
toutes les grandes villes
avec une vitesse estimée à 280 km heure
le type 135 semblait être la machine
idéale mais son autonomie était trop
courte
il approcha les industriels
aéronautiques anglais pour qui lui
dessine un avion d'affaires rapide
capable de relier les principales
capitales européennes et ce fut le
projet de bristol tu choisis
ils construisirent un prototype baptisé
team 140 me commandée et financée par
other mais cet avion pendant les vols
d'essai se montra plus rapide de 75 km
heure que les chasseurs en série dans la
r f ce qui fit sensation
avec un fuselage modifier le nouvel
avion reçu de bristol mercury 6 2 650
chevaux à la place des ac oui là
les courses de décollage et
d'atterrissage furent radicalement
raccourcie par l'ajout de voler sous les
ailes et la visibilité du pilote était
améliorée grâce à des panneaux de
perspectives sur le nez
plainte rennais fut réduite en
permettant aux trains d'atterrissage de
se replier à l'intérieur des nacelles
des moteurs
au moment du premier vol du prototype le
12 avril 1935 la vitesse maximum avait
été porté à plus de 480 km
ces performances firent sensation car
c'était 80 km heure de plus que le
nouveau chasseur de la rs de gloucester
gladiator et 160 km plus vite que
l'intercepteur au coeur furie
le ministère de l'air réagi rapidement
et approches alain droz au maire en lui
demandant de leur prêter le type 142
pour des essais et des évaluations
comme secrétaire d'état a l'air à
l'époque de trenchs harnais du royal
fine corse other mère avait été à la
tête du premier ministère de l'air entre
1917 et 1918 c'était un patriote fervent
qui avait reconnu le potentiel militaire
du type 142
après avoir baptisé le nouvel avion
britten first il offrit le prototype 142
à la ras
il fut livrée aux établissements de
recherche de marktl am inn en juin 1935
sous l'immatriculation militaire qu'a
7557 britten forces commencent à ces
essais en vol et une fois de plus
atteint les mêmes performances
impressionnantes avec une vitesse
maximum de 490 km heure ils pouvaient
atteindre 450 km heure même à pleine
charge
avant même la création de fighter
commandes en 1936 l'état major avait
déclaré que des représailles massives
serait la seule défense efficace contre
les bombardiers allemands
donc l'accent est emporté sur la
production massive de bombardier
le ministère de l'air commencé à
discuter avec bristol de l'adaptation du
142 à des missions de bombardement
en août 1935 ils publièrent la
spécification b 28 35 qui demandait la
conversion du type 142 ans bombardier
léger avec un équipage de trois hommes
le projet fut désigné bristol 142 mm
pour militaire un mois après cette
publication le ministère de l'air
commandes à 150 machines directement sur
plan cette nouvelle version fut appelée
blé naïm marc hein
les modifications du 142e commencèrent
sans attendre
pour aménager une soute abonde interne
il fut nécessaire de passer d'une aile
basse à une aile médiane
l'envergure fut augmentée
comme sur le britannique first l'hélice
à quatre pales et appâts fixe fut
remplacée par une hamilton à trois pales
et pas variable la cellule fut renforcée
pour pouvoir supporter la charge de
bombes et la roulette de que fixe ce fut
remplacée par une roulotte escamotables
pour faire de la place un viseur de
bombardements et son opérateur le
cockpit fut élargie et du vitrage ajouté
sur l'avant donnant aussi sonné une
forme plus anguleuse
on avait une mitrailleuse qui tirait
vers l'arrière et le bas
on pouvait utiliser pour le strapping
éventuellement contre les chasseurs
ennemis ce qui m'est arrivé
mais on n'avait rien pour se protéger
d'une souris
on avait bien une tourelle dort seul
quand ils pouvaient pivoter sur 180
degrés un peu vers le dessous mais
c'était vraiment pas suffisant
en dépit de sa vitesse le blé neymar
qu'un était pauvre marc mai et même
pratiquement désarmés
le prototype fut livrée à marktl am inn
et fit son premier vol le 25 juin 1936
des tests importants surmené
après le remplacement des moteurs par
les mercury 8 2 840 chevaux la version
militaire plus lourdes arrivait à une
vitesse maximale à peine inférieure à
celle du prototype 140
le ministère de la relance à la
production et en novembre 1936 le
premier blé mind série quitte l usine
bristol
la première unité à en prendre livraison
en mars 1937 puis le squadron 114 basée
à houston
malheureusement le premier avion se
retourne alors d'un accident
d'atterrissage et fut complètement
détruit
à l'été le squadron 114 était
complètement équipé et leur blé naïm
faire une apparition au meeting aérien
de la rff de 1937 à hendon
fut une fête épique on a fait des
attaques simulées les attaques simulées
contre l'aérodrome et les chasseurs
étaient derrière nous
il ne pouvait nous attraper car ils
avaient été conçus pour être l'avion le
plus rapide au monde
dans les 18 mois suivant ses autres
squadron de bombardier virent le jour et
en janvier 1938 le premier squadron le
30 basées outre-mer en irak reçu ses
marques un
ses avions avait un équipage de trois
hommes un pilote un observateur
également navigateur et bombardier est
un opérateur radio mitrailleur
en termes de vitesse de complexité le
blé n'a une meute représentait un énorme
bond en avant par rapport à ses
prédécesseurs biplan comme le procureur
ou le hawker dix mots avec ses volets
son train rétractable ses hélices à pas
variable
les pilotes trouvèrent leur conversion
sur blé naïma c'est difficile
les accidents sur fréquents et au
déclenchement de la guerre l'aéronef
avait perdu 10% des blés naïm en service
plusieurs accidents fatals survint alors
que les squadron était en pleine
transition
j'ai vu pas mal d'accidents un
atterrissage trop rapide ou décoller un
avion qui avait pris trop d'angle et qui
a fini par décrocher
s'est écrasé début par la fenêtre cela
arrivait parfois
et bien qu'étant une machine rapide il
n'avait pas la grande autonomie et les
capacités d'emport importante des autres
bombardiers bimoteur hewitt linden et
wellington
ces chiffres rangez le blé naïm parmi
les bombardiers léger mais grande est
intéressant grâce à sa grande capacité à
accepter une grande variété de missions
en décembre 1938 le blé nymark un f
entrée en service comme chasseur à long
rayon d'action
extérieurement il était quasiment
identique au bombardier mais il avait un
pote spécial monté sous le fuselage à la
place de la soute à bomber le pod
contenait quatre mitrailleuses browning
calibre 0,303 fixe diriger d'un l'avant
cette configuration n'avait aucun effet
sur les performances
même les 2000 munitions embarqué pour
les browning était plus légère que la
charge normale de bombes
quelques 200 marques 1 furent modifiées
en version de chasse en utilisant des
kits de conversion fournis par l'usiné
ferroviaire d'ashford
ses avions furent affectés à pas moins
de vingt squadron de chasse si squadron
de défense côtière et quatre autres
unités d'outre-mer
lorsque la bataille d'angleterre
commence à moins de 18 mois plus tard si
squadron de chasse équipés de blé naïm
se retrouvèrent au sein de la force du
fighter comme wendel
bien avant le début de la guerre des
recherches étaient conduites pour
concevoir une installation radar
suffisamment petites pour être installé
dans un bimoteur rapide
l'objectif étant de défendre
l'angleterre contre les bombardiers de
la luftwaffe l'aerf prévoyaient de
développer une force d'intercepteurs
capable d'opérer de nuit puisque le blé
nam était la seule machine disposant de
suffisamment de place pour installer le
nouveau système et son opérateur le
chasseur marque un puits choisi pour
cette mission de chasse de nuit
le radar emporté accords du plaza était
le premier radar jamais installé dans un
chasseur de nuit novell à la naissance
il n'y avait jamais rien eu de tel à
bord d'un bombardier ou de tout autre
avion
je crois que le premier radar
d'interception a été utilisée sur le blé
nine
tous les chasseurs de nuit conçu par la
suite comprenait un radar
parallèlement des tentatives pour
transformer le blé n'a eu mon appareil
de reconnaissance photos furent
entreprises
mais après la construction d'un
prototype p r marc hein sa vitesse
maximum s'avérait être trop basse pour
une version non armés
en 1938 la production du mark 1 commence
à être remplacée par une nouvelle
version le mark iv ayant reçu la
désignation type 142 l aile pour
l'endroit angie long rayon d'action le
mark iv était équipé de moteurs bristol
mercury xv et de 920 chevaux
l'envergure et la hauteur restés les
mêmes que pour le marc hein mais son nez
était plus long d'un mètre lui conférant
une longueur de 14 m ce nouvel avion
aussi le surnom de blenheim à long nez
hawat aux
deux types de blé naïm les cours ou les
longs
et
le nez court était utilisé comme
chasseur de nuit night fights il y avait
environ 10 squadron donné cours lorsque
la guerre a commencé
ils ont agrandi le nez sawada pour
améliorer la vision pour les
bombardements à haute altitude
l'observateur est alors rejoindre le nez
afin d'utiliser le viseur pour les
bombardements a vu
une table de navigation était installé
sur le côté gauche et le viseur de
bombardements du côté droit
en raison de la gêne occasionnée aux
pilotes lors des phases de décollage et
d'atterrissage et des problèmes
d'éblouissement sur le perspex la
verrière du navigateur fut abc est
incurvé du côté du pilote
ce nouveau né est devenu le détail
distinctif du blé nymark 4
bien que ces moteurs plus puissants
donnèrent au mark iv une vitesse de 430
km à 11 1800 pieds c'était un tout petit
peu plus rapide que le marque qui
atteignait 381 km heure au niveau de la
mer
le plafond opérationnelle du blé nymark
4e 22 min ye était légèrement inférieur
à celui de blé nymark 1 en raison de
l'augmentation de son poids et de la
charge de bond supérieur de 210 qu'il
met le mark iv avec deux avantages en
termes de performance sur le mark 1
l'ajout de réservoir de carburant
supplémentaire dans les ailes du nez par
augmentait sa distance franchissable de
560 km et d'autre part son autonomie de
plus de trois heures
les premiers marquent quatre équipes r
le 90e squadron à partir de mars 1939 à
la suite de plusieurs tests sur les
premiers modèles produit un certain
nombre d'améliorations fut réalisé
plaques de blindage et des réservoirs de
carburant auto obturant furent installés
et deux mitrailleuses browning monté sur
la tourelle dorsale en remplacement de
la simple wickers cas du mk en plus de
la mitrailleuse d'origine tirant vers
l'avant une deuxième mitrailleuse
commandé à distance est dirigée vers
l'arrière fut ajoutée dans un carénage
sous le nez de l'avion comme sur le mark
une nacelle à canon fut utilisé pour le
transformer en chasseur une fois de plus
à vos et roots furent choisis comme sous
traitants
et cette fois lusine bristol de filton
ne produisait que 10% des 3297 beinheim
mart 4 à vos réalisations 155 des
machines produites en angleterre tandis
que l' usine de route se taillaient la
part du lion avec plus de 2000 machines
sortant des lignes de production de ce
pic près de liverpool
en plus de la production anglaise
susceptibles d'être interrompu par les
bombardements allemands plus de 1000
marques quatre furent construits au
canada sous licence par serge steiner
kraft limite à la version canadienne
était nommé bolingbroke
alors que le mark iv a été le plus
produit de tous les blés naïm sa cellule
servi de base pour la troisième et
dernière variante le marquent cinq
derniers membres de la famille blé naïm
à entrer en service
le 3 septembre 1939 la grande-bretagne
déclara la guerre à l'allemagne nazie
quelques heures plus tard humble et naïm
marque cadre du squadron 139 décoller
pour une mission de reconnaissance dans
la région de wilhem seven et le n 6215
entrer dans l'histoire comme étant le
premier avion britannique à franchir la
frontière allemande pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale le lendemain dit blé
naïm venant de what i shall effectuèrent
le premier raid du beurre commandes de
la guerre lorsqu ils attaquèrent la
flotte allemande à schilling la cible
principale de la mission était le
croiseur de poche admiral chaîne mais en
plein jour la flaque était intense
l'hymne beinheim lancèrent leur attaque
mais les banques de 500 livres à
explosion retardé n'explose et repas et
rebondir sur le fond lourdement blindée
du navire un bombardier s'écrasa sur le
croiseur emden et quatre autres ne put
rentrés à leur base avec 50 % de pertes
le raid préfigurait les opérations à
venir de squadron de blé naïm avait
rejoint la france en compagnie de fait
les bateaux de l'advanced sound strike
force et 4 squadron supplémentaires
rejoignirent l'air component pour
appuyer directement les forces
expéditionnaires emplettes
leur autonomie étant trop limité pour
atteindre les cibles à l'intérieur du
territoire allemand
les deux groupes de blé naïm se
concentrait sur les navires allemands
globalement leur attaque ne donnait pas
grand chose mais le 11 mars il obtint
cependant un succès notable le p4800 52
humble et naïm marque 5 bombarde à
écouler un sous marin le but 31 près des
côtes d'irlande ce fut le premier succès
de la rn de ce genre
le 10 mai 1940 hitler envahit les pays
bas et la france et comme les allemands
contournait la ligne maginot les forces
expéditionnaires anglaise se dirigèrent
vers la belgique
le fight of command fut appelé afin
d'apporter un soutien supplémentaire et
ciblée nine du squadron 600 city of
london tentèrent de détruire l'aérodrome
de vannes avait déjà occupé par les
allemands
intercepté par une douzaine de
messerschmidt 110,5 des cibles et nine
furent décembre
pendant la bataille de france les pertes
de blé nine l'ordre d'attac turne
atteignait un niveau insupportable
en seulement six jours le squadron 114
perdit la plupart de ses avions et le
139 7 de ses 9 avr les squadron 15 et
sans faire dire 50 % de leurs effectifs
onze des douze blaine du squadron 82 sur
tabac tue
en trois jours le nombre de bombardier
anglais en france passe à 235 à
seulement 72
rien que pour le 14 mai 40 blenheim
effet le bateau furent perdues
l'emploi de bombardier léger deux jours
quasiment sans escorte de chasse s'était
avéré désastreux
bien qu'il soit capable de surpasser les
vieux chasseur biplan de 3915 en 1940
les chasseurs monoplan était entré en
service et le blé naïm était totalement
dépassé
en attaquant des cibles comme des ponts
les colonnes de blindés eblé naïm et
batteur subissait une pluie de feu tirés
par les chasseurs allemands
blindage inadaptée armements défensifs
désespérément faible et sans escorte de
chasse c'est par ce quad run entier
qu'il se faisait descendre
paul ricci un pilote de chasse du
squadron 1 pendant la bataille de france
écrit vite à propos de la bravoure des
équipages des squadron de bombardier
d'urnes les gars des battles et blé même
de la sf étaient de véritables héros il
n'avait aucun des avantages des pilotes
de chasse et prenait deux fois plus de
risques il savait qu'à chaque décollage
leurs chances de revenir est et faible
mais ils n'ont jamais reculer ni jamais
hésité on les admire est tout ce sont
les respecter et notre plus grand regret
était que nous étions incapables de les
protéger
a mené des opérations très en profondeur
à l'intérieur du territoire hollandais
occupée par les allemands
des opérations de bombardement de dépôt
de munitions dans les forêts
ou même dans d'inkerman
je me souviens d'une mission en
particulier on épaulait l'évacuation des
troupes à dunkerque
calais blenheim était à dunkerque
pour appuyer les opérations
on est arrivé à 6 avions pour attaquer
une maison proche d'une école où on
voyait des canaux
on avait peur des chasseurs allemands
car on ne pouvait pas les voir l'arrivée
on attendait de voir les lumières de
leurs tirs
c'était la seule façon de savoir qu'ils
étaient là
à toi et son spa on a été touchés ce
jour là
on est rentré bien que trois avions et
dû faire des atterrissages forcés sans
doute parce que leur hydraulique avait
été détruite
leur train d'atterrissage ne pouvait
donc plus sortir
après dunkerque un les rescapés des
squadron de bombardier léger rentrer en
angleterre pour être réaffectés
lorsque la france tombe à en juin 1940
l'angleterre était face au risque d'une
invasion imminente et les squadron de
blé naïm reçurent deux missions qui
s'avérèrent au dessus de leurs capacités
mais les avions étaient disponibles en
quantité en l'absence d'une meilleure
machine il n'y avait rien d'autre à
envoyer
pendant la bataille d'angleterre les
blés naïm heureux sur la mission de
détruire les barges et autres navires en
construction dans les ports de la manche
en préparation de l'invasion de
l'angleterre
leur second rôle était de bombarder les
aérodromes côtier utilisé par la
luftwaffe pour frapper l'angleterre ces
missions ont été effectuées deux jours
est généralement à basse altitude le
retour sur investissement plus largement
défavorable les pertes une fois encore
été énorme
le 13 août le squadron 82 fut chargé
d'attaquer l'aérodrome de aalborg au
danemark et pour la seconde fois onze
des douze blé naïm pu redescendre
pendant ce temps les blés nine martin
indus fighter commandes furent engagées
contre lui bombardiers allemands
pendant la nuit du 22 juillet 1940
humble et naïm un test de l'unité
d'interception de tang mer des 110 un
dornier 17 ce qui était la première
victoire est rien assisté par radars au
dessus de l'angleterre
bien qu'il fût le premier avion à
importer le très secret radar
d'interception le blé naïm manqué
d'autonomie et de puissance de feu pour
devenir un chasseur de nuit efficace
pendant l'hiver 1940 il allait être
remplacé par le bristol pour fighter une
bien meilleure machine bien plus rapide
en janvier 1941 la rfa d'opta une
tactique plus offensive et commença à
monter ses premières opérations circus
dans le but de détruire le plus de
chasseurs allemands possible les blés
naïm furent envoyés à l' attaquent des
cibles choisies en europe occupée
utilisé comme appât il était escorté par
un nombre impressionnant de chasseurs le
10 janvier ciblé mind du 114e squadron
menait le premier circus lorsqu ils
attaquèrent le dépôt de munitions
allemandes dans la forêt de guînes près
de qanin les bombardiers était escorté
par 72 chasseurs
le résultat de ce circus fut loin d'être
aussi bon qu'espéré
les revendications de destruction de
chasseurs allemands furent largement
surestimée et les pertes de la rfc levé
au double de celle de la luftwaffe sur
une période de six semaines entre juin
et juillet 123 pilotes de chasse de la
rff eurent porté manquant
le 28 avril deux groupes de blé naïm
commencèrent la première opération
chanel stop
partie intégrante des opérations anti
navires de la rfc raid été conçu pour
empêcher les convois allemands
d'utiliser le détroit de douvres deux
jours
mais les navires couverts par la chasse
est un grand nombre de flagship
infligèrent d'obenheim des pertes
toujours très élevé
l'opposition était féroce et lorsque
trois blé magma attaqué un convoi au
large des côtes de hollande ils
rencontrèrent un barrage de décès à
venant de huit navires spécialement
affectés à la défense d'un seul
pétrolier en dépit de bien pauvre
résultats avec vraiment bien peu de
navires coulés les raids chanel stop se
poursuivirent l'année suivante mais
pendant l'été 1941 les blés naïm
effectuèrent de raid remarquable
le 4 juillet nous avions du deuxième
groupe attaquèrent le port de brême deux
jours et à très basse altitude
le squadron 105 conduit par le wind
commandeur juli edwards descola de
swanton more lie avec une couverture
nuageuse nul
face à une défense aérienne très lourde
quatre avions furent descendus mais les
dommages causés à brême considérable
pilotant levé 6028 à la hauteur des
cheminées la viande edwards fut touché
plus de vingt fois pendant l'attaqué des
huit avions survivants il fut le dernier
à rentrer à la base
vingt jours plus tard le 22 juillet il
recevait la troisième victoria cross
attribués aux bombers commandes
formidable courage détermination et
autorités pendant l'opération
le 12 août 54 blenheim du deuxième
groupe des colères pour ce qui allait
être est de loin la plus dangereuse de
leur mission
l'un des plus formidables raid mené par
les blés naïm s'est déroulé en août 1941
lorsque 54 blé nain il fut renvoyé
attaquer une cible vers cologne
s'est éteint des premiers raids pénétrer
aussi profondément dans le territoire à
l'autre mais c'était une cible
importante
de souvenirs que j'ai de cette mission
comme vos lions à très basse altitude
c'est l'accueil exceptionnel des
hollandais
des fermiers dans leurs champs qui nous
faisait de grands gestes en voyant nos
qu'aucun anglaise
révision alors ce que ça signifiait
d'être en territoire occupé par les
allemands quand cette vague de celui à
cesser mon navigateur m'a dit que nous
étions à la frontière entre la hollande
et l'allemagne n'ont pas de chasseurs
des scores par ceux ci avait fait demi
tour ou en arrivant sur les côtes
landaises à cause de leur autonomie de
vol insuffisantes ont perdu tous des
nôtres sur les 54 avions a participé au
raid mais ce fut l'un des plus
formidables jamais mené à l'intérieur du
territoire allemand
à la fin de 1941 des avions plus
modernes et est entré en service dans la
r f sur le théâtre d'opérations européen
les blés nine du fighter commandes été
remplacé par le bristol go fighter
tandis que ceux du beurre commandes
furent supplanté par le douglas boston
et le de havilland mosquito
la dernière opération du baume leur
commande sur blé naïm fut un raid
d'intrusion sur kaunas book effectué par
le squadron 18 le 17 août 1940
lorsque l'italie déclara la guerre à
l'angleterre en juin 1940 le
commandement du moyen-orient avec une
force de bombardements de 14 fois drones
dont neuf volets sur bienne
ce furent ces machines qui effecteur le
premier raid contre le nouvel ennemi en
attaquant les aérodromes italien
à cause de l'invasion de la grèce par
les italiens en octobre quatre d'entre
eux furent détachées afin d'épauler
l'armée hellénique
dans un premier temps ils rencontrèrent
un relatif succès mais quand les
allemands à 20 en renfort des italiens
en avril 1941 les blés naïm marque subir
de lourdes pertes le 13 6 avions du
squadron 2111 attaquèrent les premières
colonnes allemandes dans le défilé de
monastir
intercepté par des messerschmitt 109
tous les six sur abattu
peu de temps après le centre et squadron
perdit tous ses avions lorsque la
luftwaffe bombarde à sa base de nyamata
ne cherchons qu'à rentrer chez nous dans
nos squadron en angleterre
mais cette époque sans nous avons été
envoyée en grèce parce que les italiens
avaient attaqué en grèce et en albanie
le gouvernement anglais avait proposé
son aide
la grèce ne voulait pas provoquer les
allemands a refusé toute participation
des troupes anglaises
ont toutefois accepté une contribution
de l'aef
quelques squadron il fut renvoyé
et mon unité qui opéraient sur blé
neymar 4 à long et à long rayon d'action
en fait
nous avons été utilisés pour faire des
missions de reconnaissance photo
nous avons photographié des aérodromes
allemand ces concentrations de troupes
jusqu'en yougoslavie et en bulgarie
le tout de façon clandestine pour nous
provoquer les allemands d'aucune manière
à ce qu'elle tient de façon à ce qu'ils
n'interviennent pas en faveur des
italiens
et ça a continué jusqu'en mars lorsque
le reste de notre unité nous a rejoint
nous avons retrouvé une activité normale
tout en restant persuadé que les
allemands allaient intervenir d'un
moment à l'autre
nous sommes souvent intervenu dans la
zone de combats
c'était assez excitant car on savait que
les allemands allaient attaquer
l'espionnage avec les avions civils
italiens comme des touristes
nous devions pas les problèmes
les allemands sont passés à l'offensive
et une partie de notre squadron s'est
installé au nord sur un petit terrain en
herbe et opérés et
sont tous morts pendant les attaques
allemandes
alors que les restes de la haye rêve se
retirer vers l'egypte 30 squadron était
resté en crète mais furent anéanties
lorsque les allemands envahirent lille
en mai 1941
depuis le début de la guerre dans le
désert en afrique du nord les squadron
de blé naïm appuyait la viiie armée
anglaise en bombardant les troupes de
lax autant que leur 0 2 en seulement six
semaines une escouade retrait et 18
avait perdu 55 appareils
la suite d'une mission d'appui au sol en
novembre 1942 le wind commandeur young
malcom reçu une victoria cross à titre
posthume lorsque les douze planning du
squadron 18 furent descendus par des
chasseurs messerschmidt
c'était la deuxième victoria cross
attribuer un pilote de blé naïm est elle
marquée pour cet avion la fin des
opérations de jours dans le désert
la clé stratégique pour interrompre les
voies d'approvisionnement de
l'afrikakorps de rommel péter l'île de
man les blés nine supplémentaires venant
du deuxième book en angleterre
arrivèrent emmener des reines antinavire
ton produit qu'on voile bien que leur
taux de réussite fut assez élevé le prix
à payer en avion et en équipage fut une
fois encore élevé le squadron 107 à lui
seul subi 90 % de perte sur une période
de 12 semaines
sur trouvait à
105 aylwin ce qu'ont
été leurs dernières semaines à mal j'ai
effectué cinq missions avec eux
suite j'ai été transféré ou squadron 109
tandis que le 105 rentrait à la maison
j'étais sûr jean pilote à l'époque six
semaines plus tard j'étais monté en
grade pour combler les trous dans les
effectifs
cette action les navires les convois de
navires qui acheminait des
approvisionnements
à malte l'un de mes grands souvenirs ses
devoirs faits une mission de nuit
il y avait des navires dans un port
sicilien très bien escorté
qu'il aurait été suicidaire de les
attaquer en plein jour
avec un autre équipage
ont mené une attaque au clair de lune et
à très basse altitude contre ces navires
ce fut une mission ils sont
mon précédent vol de nuit sur blé n'a
commenté à 6 mois langage était encore
en formation au sein de l'unité de
transformation opérationnelle
nous volions de nuit pour une mission de
combat
j'ai été très
impressionné
j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs de mal
15e exécution des missions importantes
afin de couler les navires qui allait
vers l'afrique du nord
au déclenchement des hostilités en
extrême orient la rff avait trois
squadron de bombardier et un squadron de
chasse équipés de marque 1
lorsque les japonais envahir la malaisie
en décembre 1941 les blés nine du
squadron 90 furent les premiers à
attaquer
les trois squadron basée là furent
littéralement balayés du ciel avant même
de décoller le 9 décembre le squadron 60
était en train de se préparer au
décollage quand les chasseurs japonais
ont attaqué leur aérodrome de à leur
star si le premier beinheim parvint à
décoller et 11 autres avions furent
complètement détruits au sol
piloté par le flight du lieutenant scarf
l'avion survivants mena une mission en
solitaire avec succès mais au moment de
rentrer à la base ce car ce fut blessé
mortellement la troisième victoria cross
décerner un pilote de blesme heim lui
fut accordé le 26 juin 1946
en plus de leur mission en malaisie les
blés mind combattirent à singapour à
sumatra à java en birmanie et en inde
singapour tomber en 1940 et les unités
rescapés fürth évacués vers sumatra
en février ils attaquèrent la flotte de
débarquement japonaise au large des
côtes de sumatra
ils coulèrent plusieurs navires il était
bien trop peu nombreux pour empêcher le
débarquement japonais et finalement ils
durent battre en retraite cette fois-ci
verges à vannes
l'histoire se répète encore et bien que
de moins en moins nombreuses la rfa tac
à la flotte qui faisait cap vers les
côtes de java
le 1er mars les japonais débarquèrent et
en moins de 24 heures les blés naïm
survivants du squadron 84 furent tous
détruits
ou qu'ils purent opéré en asie les blés
naïm étaient submergés par les chasseurs
ennemis qui leur étaient de plus
largement supérieures
contre les 0 il n'avait aucune chance de
survie
vers le printemps 1943 la plupart des
squadron d'extrême orient avait reçu des
avions plus récents et les blés naïm
avaient été retirés du service des
unités de combat d'outre-mer
aujourd'hui le bristol lehmann de
l'aircraft resterez chaîne compagnie est
le seul exemplaire de cet avion encore
un état de vol au printemps 1993 le wmz
pris l'air pour la première fois depuis
des décennies
il était le second blais même
complètement restauré par l'équipe daher
c'est
une erreur de pilotage cause à la
destruction du premier avion en juin
1987 moins d'un mois après la fin de la
remise en état
l'avion et les douze ans de travail
avaient été réduits à néant
l'avion ayant été totalement détruit
menés par grin warner l'équipe commencé
à travailler sur le deuxième appareil en
janvier 1988
il avait beaucoup appris de leur
première restauration et cette fois il
se fixèrent l'objectif d'y arriver en
cinq ans
en partant des morceaux d'un bolingbroke
le wm scènes furent construits par
sections chacune étant restaurer
séparément avant d'être assemblés
le processus de restauration est à la
fois laborieux et difficile
chaque morceau doit être soigneusement
démontés nettoyés et tester avant d'être
éventuellement réutiliser
lorsque les pièces d'origine sont
endommagés ou trop détériorée il faut
les remplacer avec des pièces fabriquées
spécialement où dénicher ailleurs dans
de nombreux cas les panneaux de
revêtement ont été refaits de toutes
pièces
les moteurs mercury du wmz ont été
reconstruits en utilisant des pièces
venues d'autres moteurs
l'ingénieur en chef et pilote pour la rc
et john romaine
sous son impulsion le projet progressa
et arriva au moment où les moteurs et
des prêts à être installées sur l'avion
les moteurs bristol mercury sont des
moteurs en étoile à 9 cylindres mines un
réducteur pour régler la vitesse de
rotation de l'hélice
dans cette configuration nous obtenons
une puissance de 8 175 chevaux par
moteur qu'on peut pousser à plus de 900
ce que nous ne faisons jamais pour
économiser le potentiel de ces moteurs
le plus longtemps possible
de ce
cet avion était le dernier qui restait
au canada où il faisait partie des
habits backup au cas où les usines
anglaises aurait été bombardé
et pour cause cette usine ayant été
bombardé deux fois pendant la guerre il
était utilisé pour l'entraînement avancé
au canada puis abandonnée à l'état
d'épave total sur le bord d'un terrain
vont récupérer a patrouillé par bateau
on remplace l essentiel des pièces et
les revêtements
nous avons utilisé 18 moteur différent
pour pouvoir reconstruire deux qui
marche
notre premier blé naïma volée en mai
malheureusement il fut totalement
détruits dans un accident au bout de
seulement quelques semaines
le groupe a décidé de recommencer
c'est donc le deuxième avion que nous
avons reconstruit il est actuellement le
seul en état de vol dans le monde
en avril 1993 l'avion était finalement
prêt pour les essais moteurs
moins d'un mois plus tard il eut la
cérémonie de baptême est le premier vol
sous les yeux d'une foule constituée
d'anciens membres d'équipage de blé naïm
et d'inviter l'actuel vie contreur mère
lui donna le nom de spirit of britain
first
je voudrais dire combien nous sommes
reconnaissants envers la warner
qui reproduit
ou plutôt recréer ce merveilleux avions
baptisé à la mémoire de mon grand père
va spirit of britain first
c'était le nom qu'il avait donné au
premier prototype de cet avion qui avait
été construit afin de prouver
que l'on pouvait produire un avion
qui surclasserait les avions de la
luftwaffe de l'époque cap d'ail que mon
grand-père avait vu en allemagne
je voulais aussi les remercier au nom de
lady est parmi nous
car cet avion porte les couleurs de
celui de son mari aujourd'hui disparu
qui fut un des grands héros de cette
guerre
il volait sur un avion un blé naïma
semblable à celui ci
est dans la mémoire est associé à
l'immatriculation de cet avion
je baptise cet avion spirit of britain
first
nous sommes fiers de faire voler cet
avion comme hommage au blender
qui ont été les héros des grands feux
d'un menu début de la guerre
les trois longues années qui ont suivi
dans toutes les missions possibles
attaques de navires attaque d'aérodrome
à basse altitude comme avions de chasse
comme avion multirôles avant l'heure
comme l'ont montré les tornado pendant
la guerre du golfe
le blé naïm avait un rôle ingrat et
dangereux à tenir
nous le faisons voler en hommage ses
équipages et dans l'esprit britten forts
comme les blés naïm boys si loyaux qui
ont souvent sacrifié leur vie
l'équipe actuelle a travaillé très dur
pour permettre à cet avion les à nouveau
et de le conserver en état de vol en
hommage à 16 heures
portant la livrée des chasseurs de nuit
du 68e squadron il représente l'avion
d'un des plus remarquables pilote de la
rs le wing commandeur marc sprenger
fils de lord beaverbrook il fut crédité
de 8 victoires aériennes et devant le
seul pilote de la rs à être
opérationnels du premier au dernier jour
de la guerre
lorsqu'il prit le commandement du 68e
squadron après la bataille d'angleterre
il reçu pour mission de mener à bien les
développement des techniques de chasse
de nuit opérationnel de là et rêve
plutôt que de passer sur le nouveau
fighter tekken préférera garder son
fidèle beinheim wmz
on
lorsqu'il fut conçu soixante ans plus
tôt le blé naïm fut pour une brève
période à la pointe de son époque
lorsque la guerre arrive à quatre ans
plus tard il en était à l'exact opposé
face à des avions bien supérieur ces
équipages paient un lourd tribut et ce
jour après jour
mais ils continuèrent ils jouèrent un
rôle majeur dans les premiers moments de
la guerre le temps que la différence
technologiques soient comblées
le dernier des blés naïm en état de vol
au monde le wm aide symbolise le
formidable courage et la détermination
des blés my boys
bon
côté sécurité
blood
m